about our company and about who we are
and about this upcoming program that we
will be starting next week okay and
please do let me know if you can't see
my screen or you can't hear me well I'll
make sure that I can pause and we
started that's needed so the Onix logic
program for genomic data analysis will
be starting next week and we're excited
about this program that has been piloted
in several universities already around
the world in the u.s. we've worked with
a lot of faculty and groups including
primarily the Taliban chromatics
Research Center which is a Research
Center out of University of Haifa in
Israel where the team has been working
for the past decade to develop
cutting-edge computational tools for
genomic and multiply Amish data analysis
so we're excited to now make this
program available online and we'll talk
a little bit more about the topics that
we will be covering who is going to be
involved and how this is practically
going to work hoping that everybody is
familiar with the topics and we can
start our program next week so what we
want to do in this program is to bring
awareness about genomic data types of
genomic data types of analysis
techniques interpretation techniques and
this is going to be a very comprehensive
program that will exclusively focused on
the genomic aspect and we'll talk a
little bit about what that actually
means in the context of a variety of
projects and we will have 16 online
meetings it's going to last for about
three months and then we will also have
extensive time with support from our
staff that could learn in the context of
an independent project or a project that
we work on as a group and what we are
going to do throughout this program is
bring some of our team members
who are going to be covering specific
topics supporting the research projects
or helping identify datasets and ways to
analyze the data for each participant of
this program what we want to do today is
kind of talking a little bit about you
know what are the goals of this program
what are some of the resources that will
be available during this program how
will this actually work and then we'll
show you some of the things that we've
prepared and also introduce you to some
of our team members at the end so as you
all know DNA three billion base pairs we
have the human DNA so a lot of
information on that in the DNA code that
basically refers to the variants in
those nucleotides or groups of
nucleotides that you can analyze with a
variety of statistical methods machine
learning methods but also interpretation
is important here because in so much
information finding the information that
is related to a specific phenotype or
dad could be informative in an
understanding of a biological problem is
the main challenge so what we'll do in
the program is first of all go through
some of these introductory things to
refresh everybody's memory and
understand what are we dealing with when
we say genomic how is genomic different
from any other kind of garlic what are
some of the technologies that are used
to sequence this kind of data what are
some of the analysis methods and what
are some of the challenges that we are
trying to solve when we analyze process
the data annotate the data and try to
interpret this data in the context of a
biological question then we will talk
about specifically processing of genomic
data how do we address the different
types of sequencing for example whole
exome sequencing whole genome sequencing
what are some of the attributes of
next-generation sequencing that we need
to be aware of like sequencing depth
how do we map the different mappers are
available what kinds of references do we
use so we will really go step-by-step
into all of those aspects and we'll
actually do this in a number of meetings
what we found is that over the course of
the past couple of years working with a
different a variety of groups that
included groups of biology and clinical
researchers as well as students starting
from high school and bachelor bachelor
level we've found that it's very
important for us to make sure that we
build it up the information to the level
of everybody's understanding so that
everybody can contribute to the actual
analysis and interpretation of a data
set
and so we've been doing this for quite a
while and we structured this program the
way that we think is going to be
effective for anyone irrelevant of their
background to be able to go from knowing
something about genomic data and genomic
data analysis to actually being able to
do it in the context of their own
question their own biological question
so for example some of the things that
we think are important here is the
ability to really understand that the
various next-generation sequencing
techniques that allow us to study a
variety of biological or molecular
biology phenomenons like for example we
can look at variants in DNA we can look
at expression of our name we can look at
DNA methylation we can look at micro RNA
signaling and other aspects of what's
happening at the subcellular level but
understanding what type of data and
finding their appropriate methods is
critical for us to be able to analyze
that and get meaningful insights from
the data we also understand that not
everybody is technically equipped to
process that data independently so we've
created an environment where you can
both learn and do the practical
activities anywhere without having high
performance computing computational
environment without having the technical
code
skills and without really knowing the
ins and outs of the methods so we will
try to get quickly to a practical
hands-on session where everybody gets to
analyze data and start looking at what
is inside a data set and so the first
step is really understanding what is
this data then we'll talk about what
kinds of variants what kinds of DNA
variants are we expecting to find in
that state because we're studying the
DNA we are interested in a variety of
mutations for example germline mutations
in the DNA that are a result that are
passed on from generation to generation
they're hereditary or somatic mutations
mutations that appear as a result of
cells cell replication and often occur
as a result of some irregularities and
the mechanisms that control cell
replication so somatic mutation hallmark
of variety of cancers we'll also talk
about non point variations for example
copy number variation chromosomal
instability and others there are an
important aspect and require a specific
type of an approach that is different
from the analysis of germline or somatic
mutations so we'll dive deep into that
and we'll talk about how DNA varies what
do we use to analyze that kind of data
and then how do we actually use that
information and we'll have a couple of
sessions just focused on some of those
aspects so we'll see how there's a
number of different types of for example
single nucleotide variations
substitutions insertions deletions or as
we commonly refer to them in those and
how are they different from single point
mutations in terms of their impact on
the product of that specific sequence
oftentimes thinking of it as a way to
understand the data the raw data that we
find in the sequencing reads and try to
align it with other information that we
can gather from a lot of different other
databases to understand the impact
of those mutations on the overall
sequence we'll also talk about that
analysis of these mutations once we have
identified all of the positions where
there is a change the question is what
are those changes going to do what is
going to be either impact for example
the impact on a gene a lot of times we
focus on for example whole exome
sequencing where only they expressed
genes are analyzed for variants to try
and understand how those variants would
impact the codon sequence which will
have an impact on the protein that is
being produced from the DNA via
transcription to the RNA and translation
into protein and so we'll look at the
relationship between the sequence of the
amino acids and the sequence on the DNA
we'll also look at different types of
mutations missense nonsense frameshift
mutations mutations that have a
different type of impact and we'll look
at other methods in silico methods that
will help us understand the impact of
mutations and how significant they are
also it's important to annotate those
mutations annotate those regions where
we found a lot of mutations or even
single nucleotide mutations using
reference databases or other types of
studies that produce a lot of reliable
consistent results as well as looking at
other statistical methods that help us
correlate genotype to phenotype so we'll
take a look at several examples where we
can use the information in the DNA
sequence as a result of processing that
data and then correlating it to a
specific phenotype like for example
arisal arising mutations that come as a
result of treatment or that help us find
the differences between genomes of
infectious agents pathogens e in
different regions
we'll also look at the protein structure
impact and Farlington animal talk about
what are some methods to understand
population genetics how do we look at
phylogeny how do we understand the
relationships that are defined by the
sequence in the DNA we'll look at some
important studies that have been used or
that have been actually developed to
find enough consistent signal in a
specific variant in a specific gene and
one of them of course is TCGA the Cancer
Genome Atlas the Cancer Genome Atlas is
a study of thousands of patients across
us a variety of cancers that allows us
to look at an individual gene level
individual nucleotide level as well as
associate phenotypes with some of the
genotypes and other types of objects
data so the advantage is also that they
have multiple levels of omics data and
we'll touch on that in the context of
trying to interpret the functional
outcome of a mutation signature we'll
also look at some of the other resources
that are available some databases that
were created specifically to annotate a
variety of mutations in different
contexts in the context of cancer where
we're talking about somatic mutations in
the context of germline mutations in the
context of different types of genomes
then we'll look at machine learning for
genomic data so machine learning has
become hot word buzzword that everybody
uses in a variety of contexts but when
we talked about machine learning and we
talked about these different analysis
techniques it's important to remember
what goes into the preparation of data
for that those methods to use the data
that we have also at the way that they
work and they work in a variety of ways
because there are several groups of
methods that are going to be applicable
to this kind of data and then we'll look
at the outcome how can this practically
be used in a variety of contexts what
there is the benefit from having a
data-driven model like a machine
learning model that can for example
predict a certain outcome of a
mutational profile in a variety of
samples that we feed into that model so
we're looking at the predictive aspect
we'll look at the data mining aspect
we'll look at how we can use different
statistical techniques like regression
and understand the factors and the
features of our data we'll take a look
at the supervised machine learning
models where we can look at
classification where we can look at
discriminant analysis we look also at
the outcome the mutational profiling and
how we can develop a signature or a
biomarker using DNA engagement now we'll
spend a lot of time on the machine
learning aspect because in a variety of
settings depending on the data type that
we have and depending on the problem
that we're trying to solve we need to
understand where to apply the different
techniques and also how to combine those
techniques together to help overcome
some of the limitations of these
conventional machine learning tools we
will look at the variety of methods and
how they work together and where their
application gives us an advantage when
we look at the DNA data and will
specifically focus on preparing that DNA
data for example when we have single
nucleus ample they include information
of change from one single nucleotide
letter to a different letter they also
have a significance and then we can
organize them in a variety of wastes
based on their position on the DNA so
when we talk about it a variant it's
important to understand how many
characteristics or descriptor we have of
those mutations to try and prepare the
data in the appropriate way but we'll
look at the application
for example unsupervised machine
learning methods like principal
component analysis clustering network
analysis and we'll look at those how can
they help understand and the variability
of samples how they can group those
samples in a variety of ways and help us
mine the data for some patterns how can
we find patterns that are related
between different samples or groups of
samples then we'll also look at
supervised machine learning where we
will use regression as a way to estimate
relationship between some factors and
then understand how to train a model so
that we can have a predictive output and
that follows under supervised machine
learning where we can have
classification regression discriminant
analysis so we'll look at some of the
applications of those methods for
genomic data and we'll do this in the
context of several examples and those
examples are going to help us understand
the biological significance as well as
the limitation of some of these methods
and the type of data that would have to
be produced if we would like to use some
of the methods that we are hearing about
now that brings us to an important part
of this program the program is
structured to provide some basic
information to give us a background so
that the biology can more easily be
related to the data it will also give us
an overview of the types and there is a
variety of data types that we need to
consider in the context of genomics then
we will also talk about the different
methods and the steps to go from raw
data to then process data that we can
for example structure and look at and
visualize to then analyze data where the
data went through several
transformations and now for example
could be compared between a variety of
samples in a categorical or a non
categorical way where we can look at
either mutations or abundance of
mutations in a particular region then we
will talk about
how do these different pathways and
pipelines apply to a variety of
challenges a variety of project
challenges now we source these projects
from public repositories so the full
dataset is available and typically these
are impactful studies that come from
high-impact journals and we want to
first of all understand how did people
that let these impactful projects how
did they use the same tools and what
kinds of conclusions that they arrived
at with the tools that they used using
the same tools we can then start
thinking about our own questions that we
might want to develop in our own project
so what we'll do is we'll look at
several examples for example in cancer
how can we understand the significance
of cancer for classification of
different types of cancer or for a
difference between a variety of cancers
how can we look at development of
treatment resist resistance to for
example tuberculosis and the resistance
to the different types of treatments
knowing the treatments from around the
world in to collect data from around the
world in a consistent manner can help us
differentiate between the types of
resistant and non resistant strains
identify what the resistant mechanism
might be and also apply the same
information to new samples so that we
can understand what them we'll also talk
about case control studies and
genome-wide Association studies so we'll
talk about how do we use this kind of
information to find global associations
associations between for example a
phenotype and this could be related to a
human disease or it could be related to
something completely different for
example raizou bacteria how can we
analyze genomic data from rise of
bacteria which is bacteria that grows
around the roots of certain plants and
understand the impact of that mutational
profiling
on a phenotype for example crop
production but we'll also want to
demonstrate how different techniques
vary between model organisms non-model
organisms organisms that have a defined
protein and gene structure and those
that have a lot of overlap like in the
pathogen world we look at a variety of
environmental factors that shape the
responses that a an organism can pose to
those environmental factors so we'll
talk about mutational Fitness for
example in pathogens we'll talk about
drug resistance as a response to an
environmental pressure we'll talk about
the way that this type of information
can be useful for cancer studies where
of course we are looking at a variety of
factors ethnicity different ages
different locations different diets
different backgrounds different
hereditary information and different
treatments so being able to leverage the
right method apply it to the right data
set and understand the question in the
context of data and methods is really
the objective of this program now here
are some of the practical examples that
I've referenced in cancer we'll look at
somatic mutations signatures of
mutations and we'll look at copy number
variation and other non single
nucleotide mutations that are going to
be important for the understanding of
factors driving hereditary risk and a
staging of cancer as well as
differentiation of cancer we'll look at
tuberculosis as a way to understand drug
resistance we look at Ebola as you know
the epidemic that happened between 2014
and 2016 gave us an insight into the way
because of next-generation sequencing we
now were able to first of all understand
the variety of genomes that we are all
Ebola virus as a whole but in reality
these are sub strains and how we can
categorize that information to
understand maybe which mutational
profile
contributed to virulence contributed to
pathogenesis and also maybe the severity
of the outcome we will also use that
information to try and apply that to
datasets where we can find for example a
different landscape of mutational
profiles for example in the new outbreak
that is going on right now or some other
outbreaks that have happened in the past
and as I mentioned riser bacteria so
it's important to understand that the
DNA code is a source of rich information
about a variety of organisms and a
variety of problems and so we wanted to
give a wide overview of some of those
ideas now before I jump into the
speakers I want to say that the project
examples that we prepared are really
built to give you some practical
hands-on experience to give you an
understanding of the biological
prob
but also to Gitmo and the program is
structured to provide sufficient time
for each one of you to be able to submit
a project idea that you think this type
of these types of analytical methods
could be applicable to and then we will
support your research effort in that ear
and do whatever is possible in the time
that we have to get there to get into a
meaningful outcome in the context of the
program now I want to introduce you to
our team and maybe let them say a few
words about them and first I would like
to introduce the subpoena who's going to
be who is now working on preparing the
the sessions the materials and the
project examples so the subpoena maybe
you can say a few words about yourself
hello everyone I am very happy that we
will be doing this course together for
the next months I am a permutation
I am from grace I have a background in
computer science and then I have a
degree from the University of Athens and
then I continued my studies in
bioinformatics again at the University
of Athens then I worked in the company
as a programmer nothing to do with my
romantics but right now for the past
three years I am banned from this and in
molecular diagnostics laboratory in in
Democritus it's a visa it's the biggest
Research Centre in Greece so in the lab
I am the only buyer from a decision I
was the only by fermentation up until
4matic four months ago everyone else is
a geneticist and we study hereditary
cancer we do targeted panel sequencing
we study genes that are that we know or
with we have a suspicion that they
propose to cancer syndromes
and I am a PhD candidate as well in my
PhD I developed some algorithms and
pipelines for their knives of DNA data
from next-generation sequencing so the
goal of our research in our lab is to
decipher the mutational spectrum of
hereditary cancer in Greece it is so in
Greece we have many subpopulations that
are a little isolated for example in
villages in mountains or in Greek
islands so we have there we have
mutations that are only found there and
are in a yes someone talking
I can hear you I'm sorry
okay so if you want to tell me something
because I can hear you I'm so sure you
can write in chat it's a gay
so what I was telling is that okay so we
study the the the population the sub
population I isolate from Greece and we
have found many founder mutations that
are found only here in Greek people we
are members of four large scientific on
shortest such as Simba and the nigma
that are trying to study here editor
cancer and the specific cancer syndromes
and for the past ten months we are one
of the four precision medicine units in
Greece the there is we are trying to to
be the hellenic precision medicine
Network here in Greece right now we are
trying to setting to set this up so in
our lab lab we have started hereditary
cancer for this precision medicine
Network the goal is to
to provide cancer patients with with
genetic testing so they can benefit from
targeted therapies and I am responsible
for everything related to burn from
attics inherited cancer for the network
this is more or less I will gladly
answer some questions if you have any
Thank You disappearing ah yes I think so
we'll have a little more time for
questions and answers
oh good thank you very much okay and
thank you and maybe it's to heal you can
also tell us a little bit more about
your background and the research at
University of Nebraska Medical Center as
well as the program and how the program
will be structured sure Thank You Ilya
thank you this veena for Kenny lecture
so good so hello everyone my name is
Sahil and I work with pine as a special
projects coordinator and my background
is into bioinformatics I did my masters
and to biomedical infomatics from
University of Nebraska Omaha and I would
be continuing with my PhD in my
informatics from University of Nebraska
Medical Center and UNMC that's what
Universal Nebraska Medical Center is
primarily involved with the cancer
research that has been going on over
there and if I talk about my role in the
whole program and it's mine is to make
sure that the operations are going
smoothly before the program if there are
any some technical difficulties or if
the users are having problems and not
able to cope with the lecture or other
things so I could help in streamlining
the process so yeah that's me and now I
would like to show you about our
resources that we have and how exactly
the program would be carried of and what
all the features we do have okay so I'm
gonna share my screen now
please let me know if you all can't see
my screen and if I am audible okay so
starting with a fullest resource that's
the educational website or the education
portal that we have and the URL is edu
dot t-- - bio dot info we do have free
courses and our free projects that
people are allowed to register and
enroll themselves we do have some of our
paid courses those are involved more
into the on the technical side but all
our basic courses are free so you are
more than welcome to explore the edu
site look around with the courses we do
have a vast collection that starts from
introduction to bioinformatics that
would walk you through each and every
step that is involved into the world of
informatics the keywords the
terminologies and then you move forward
to more technical courses in which we
have the process of carrying the RNA
seek analysis which would be covered in
transit omics one two and three genomics
we have the whole module that is
dedicated to genomics meta genomics and
epigenetics you can view the course
collections over here and you want to
have all the courses that are there on
our website so these are some of the
things that I wanted to mention about
the courses over here if I go under the
project so we do have a couple of
projects that are being up and it's
available for the users to take so most
of our projects are from the publicly
available data set so we do provide you
with the data set in order to play
around with the data and understand more
better like how the analysis was carried
out and the step-by-step analysis
you need to follow to come to a point
where the author has mentioned his
analysis or his results so that's how
the projects are designed over here and
I would yeah I would like to tell you
more about the organization page so what
our organization page is basically so if
you come down at the bottom of the edu
site you could see that there's a
section that say all sales organizations
so organizations are nothing but those
are dedicated dashboard or a dedicated
group of the participants if they are a
part of any of the program so let's say
that we are talking about the genomics
training program so we have a dedicated
a dashboard or a group for the genomics
training so if you click over here so
that's where you're gonna be coming to
so over here you could see that we have
different tabs including forum progress
what's the curriculum and the
assignments so you can directly go over
to this organization page if you would
like to register for the program yes
yeah so over here you could see that
this is the payment portal through which
you can be the part of the program and
register yourself once you are
registered to the program so you would
be having the access to this
organization page and you could explore
all the events you could look at the
curriculum what all the updates are
going on you could figure out over here
in the updates section so I'll just walk
you through on how to go ahead and pay
or register so over here you can see
that there is an option that says select
so we're gonna click on that it would
give me an overview about the program
what all courses are involved over here
and then you have the option to enter
your credit card or debit card details
now one thing that I would like to
mention to all the participants who
are the part of the webinar today since
you guys had a chance to be the part of
this webinar and are interested to know
more about the genomics so we would like
to offer you a 25% discount that would
be valid till Sunday of this week so if
you are interested to enroll yourself
into the program we would be emailing
you with the discount coupon that you
could apply while checking out and
registering for the genomics program but
just to show you how exactly it works so
you can enter the card number over here
and then over here it says discount code
so whatever the discount code we are
going to provide you you can enter that
let's say for an example I'm going to
enter fine bye over here and you can
click on it and click on apply and then
submit and checkout so it's an easy
process you don't have to juggle around
between lot of things it's just one
click away to register for the program
and once you are registered so I would
like to show you a sample organization
page like what all functionalities do we
have if you are the part of the program
so this is our another program that is
going on currently that's by informatics
for the precision oncology so since I am
the part of this program so I could see
what all events happened in the previous
weeks what's coming up so I could see
all of those events I could register
individually for those events so once
you are the part of the program all the
events that are inside that program
would be free for you so you don't have
to worry it's just to register so that
we know who is going to attend our next
program it's kind of an RSVP and then
you're gonna see all the updates over
here what have you been doing and what
is the file or the presentation that's
used during the presentation so you
gonna see all the updates under over
here we do have a forum so all our
participants are pretty active and
you like to discuss about each and
everything so they keep on adding the
topics over here and then the
participants to come comment on each
other on each other post and they try to
learn with the experiences so as you
could see that we have pretty good
quantity of the forums over here so we
have all the presentation we do share
the recordings of each and every session
that is being conducted so you could
find all the recordings over here
so that's something about the forum and
then you can have the curriculum so
curriculum would give you a an idea like
you know what all you have to have to be
prepared for and what's coming up so we
did start from introduction to precision
oncology then we went to introduction to
Big Data bioinformatics so in that way
you can keep yourself motivated to see
what's coming up and at what time or at
what date it's coming up so that's the
idea behind the curriculum and you can
have one interaction with difficulties
directly you can bring them or you can
check with us we do have a chat box
functionality over here so if at all
like you know if you're registering to
the program or if you are going through
our free courses or free projects and if
you come across with any roadblock or
any hurdle you can ping us over here and
we are pretty active and replying back
so feel free to chat with us or email us
now moving forward I would like to
highlight some of our profiles those are
the start profiles and those are the
previous participants who have been
participating in our programs and we
would like to see your profiles as well
over here in our star booths but just to
see some of the profiles I would like to
start with iron that's the profile and
you could see that he has he has a
profile picture over here he has like 20
100 points so how do you gain those
points so what's the logic behind the
point so each and each and every
activity that you do on the educational
portal
that's edu dot T dash y dot info you
will be assigned a point so let's say
that you know you registered for a
course so you're gonna get 400 points if
you complete the course you're gonna get
500 points so for each and every
activity that you're gonna conduct on
edu dot t - y dot info you're gonna get
some points and even if you do some
practical exercises on the T by info
platform you're gonna get the points as
well so that's how the points get
accumulated over here and you could see
everything under profile so we do have
different levels beginner intermediate
and expert depending upon the activities
that you do and how much points you have
gathered at the end and everyone every
participant does get a badge on the
profile - whatever program he or she
belongs to so if you are the part of the
genomics program you would be getting an
individual badge that would say um X
logic genomics program so in the profile
we could see that he has been running a
quite a number of pipelines by in with
in terms of pipeline it means the
practical exercises that he has been
doing on the teeth - PI dot info so you
could have a look over here we do have a
bottom all from MIT Kolkata and he has
been at the part of the program that has
been going on with MIT University and
you could see that he has around 14,000
points and he's an expert level the
other participant I would like to
mention is Loki
she's from Nigeria and she has been part
of our previous omics logic program and
you could see that she has around 12,000
points she's an expert and then she has
her social media account linked to the
profile so that you know all the
participants can know with whom they are
not trying to shoot the program and they
can have a more clear understanding
about the participants and can know each
other in a better way so the idea is to
build a close community of all the
people so that you know they could learn
they could explore the opportunities and
they could move forward
in the field of bioinformatics now
without racing lot of time I would like
to cover the last aspect so what what
are some special features that are
involved whenever you go ahead and take
the courses so let's say we are talking
about the genomics so over here under
the courses if you see that there is an
option that says genomics one so if
you're gonna click on genomics one
you're gonna see that this is the
outline outline of the proper course and
over here you could see the overview
like what all things are being covered
in the genomics course that's upcoming
what's the curriculum so we do have
lessons we do have the videos and we do
have the quizzes if you want to know
more about the instructor we have the
details about the instructor over here
and the reviews of all our previous
users who have been the part of the
genomics program so with the overview
over here I would like to highlight
certain things so let's say that you're
going through the course and you're not
very sure about let's say sequencing
like what exactly so you can sequencing
so you could hover around this specific
word and there would be a definition
that would come across so you could see
that what exactly is next-generation
sequencing and some of the key points
that it's essential to understand
sequencing so the idea is that you know
once you are into the course you can be
on this website and we try to educate
you at each and every level just so that
you know your learning experience
becomes easier and you don't have to
switch the windows in order to
understand the definition and then come
back again to continue with the courses
so if you click on this particular
lesson so that's where you wanna go
inside the lesson and you could see what
all is being covered over here so this
is our first lesson that says lesson 1
point 1 and what is genomics so you can
go through it what exactly it is there
is a video to have a better
understanding about what has been
covered in the field of genomics and how
could you benefit if genomic analysis
and we do have the keyword
over here that are highlighted with
specific definition which might benefit
you if you're going through the courses
we do have the quizzes yes so that you
know we do check the knowledge at each
and every level and just to make sure
that the students are the users are able
to understand what all has been covered
in the previous lecture so we do have
the quizzes over here and we do have
those supplementary materials so that
you know if you would like to dig deeper
into genomics and understand some of the
key concepts you can go ahead and refer
to the publication's
so that is about the education website
the last thing that I would just quickly
give you an overview is about the t bio
info platform and that's a second
resource where all our practical
assignments are being carried off and
the URL is server dot T - bio dot info
so this is our platform where we would
be analyzing our data so we do have the
pipelines and pipelines are nothing but
those are the set of algorithms so you
can 11 what algorithm is what and what's
the use of that specific algorithm which
algorithm is required if you want to do
your pre-processing which algorithm is
required if you want to map it on a
transcriptome or map it on a genome how
are you going to move forward find a
mutation and things like that so we do
have different sections over here NGS
data mass spec structure biology and
machine learning which includes
supervised and unsupervised analysis and
if you want to know more about these
sections you can just hover around and
you could get a more clear idea about
what exactly each section covers we do
have the demo pipelines so demo
pipelines are the way to learn and
explore and play around the d bio info
platform so you have a better
understanding of how to handle the data
and do the analysis using the class so
yeah so that was an introduction about
our resources if you have any questions
please feel free to unmute yourself or
write it down on the chat box
Thank You Sahil and again we want to
make sure that it's clear how the
programs how the program will run so
starting in starting as you can see on
the presentation that was shared we will
keep an outline of the topics that will
be covered and we will also take a look
at the different online resources that
support the lectures that will be
carried out in a similar way like what
we are doing now so essentially we will
have meetings like this
gasps penis a heel protein myself we
will be speaking about different topics
then we will have the opportunity to do
some hands-on assignments and those
hands-on assignments are going to be
related to analysis of a data set that
we first provide but eventually as you
get familiar with the methods get
familiar with the data types and what
can be done with those data types you'll
be able to work with your own data and a
lot of the methods that we are
describing here the purpose of them
being a part of the platform is for
several reasons first of all is so that
we can follow
everybody's progress and address any
roadblocks that might arise as you go
through the analysis the second one is
really an efficient and fast way to
compare many different types of analyses
without having to set up any additional
resources or libraries or we late for
your own resource computationally for
some of the analyses and some of the
datasets or so they require a lot of
time so what we want to do is
standardize that process for everybody
so irrelevant of your background
everybody can do the same tasks now if
you're more on the computational side
all the methods are going to be the
subscribe so you're free to take those
methods and build your own pipelines in
your own environment on bioconductor or
other resources and put them together in
the way that you see fit to address your
problem our goal of the program is to
build the logic of the house
provide several examples and help
everybody get through some of the major
steps that are involved in such a
process now we hope that as a result you
will also be able to generate a new
question and have your own project
design and ready for analysis and maybe
even do a significant portion of that
analysis during the course of the
program the program is going to last a
whole three months and hopefully will be
enough time for everybody to get to some
level of completion in those projects I
also want to mention that the program
that we have right now is one of four
programs that we run throughout course
of the year that includes introduction
to bioinformatics transcriptomics
genomics epigenomics and metagenomic so
we do cover a lot of these different
topics as programs and then all of them
also have an online component and a lot
of times programs that are being run at
different universities in your area
perhaps if you're in one of the areas
that we have a program where you're
wondering about a program you can reach
out to us and we can also guide you to
those programs so I hope that this
overview gave enough information for all
of you to understand the program
understand how it works understand the
topics that would be covered if you're
interested learn more about the topics
and they do look relevant you're welcome
to browse online some of the materials
that we have there can show you some of
the free resources if you want to do it
on your own time if you want to join the
program we're excited about launching
this next week if you want to look at
some of the projects you can do that as
well and as a part of the program you'll
get access to this environment that we
describe with online learning and the
online platform for data analysis that
can help you deal with a lot of data so
at this point I would just like to hand
it over to a Q&A session if you have any
questions
you're welcome to unmute yourself and
speak and we'll listen and try to answer
that or if you would like to post your
question in the chat box we're all able
to address any of the questions there as
well and and I do want to mention that
together with me
Sahil de speeder and also pro team are
available to discuss any questions and
you know we'll have time to go over the
you know twelve O'Clock limit that we
have but I thank you for joining us
today and for taking the time to listen
to what we have prepared and please go
ahead with your questions
Karia so hi everybody this is protein I
will be one of the persons who will be
kind of giving you some views and
understanding about the various aspects
of the genomics program here we have
conduct here for the next three months
so it's a media discipline as this veena
has correctly pointed out that there's
so many things and also in the beginning
Elia has told you about kind of things
that we're going to cover and we have an
equivalent mixture of theoretical
understanding and also lot of doing
things by your own hand using the t bio
platform this is a fantastic platform
which will help you to understand how
actually there is a dialysis takes place
in the real world cases problems that
are typically answered the problems that
are typically addressed and as you all
know that liver the advent of high
throughput sequencing and high to put
the data generation practices there's a
huge amount of data available which goes
hand in hand with all those in vitro and
in vivo experiments and the time is kind
of correct to say that time for those in
silico practices using to come to
analyze the data and come up to a
situation where you can predict so its
needle-in-a-haystack situation i mean
you have a big amount of data you kind
of precisely try to identify using the
statistical methods and algorithms to
pinpoint those particular area which
require deeper understanding and deeper
views as of me i am a PhD in biophysics
molecular biology and genetics and i've
been working in the industry for what an
amount of time and i have also taught in
universities as a part of a tech
biotechnology programs in india i have
been a part of mine barley for the last
three months and it has been a very good
journey with them trying to understand
getting
customs with the various operations and
I would be happy to answer all of your
many of your questions you can get back
to me via emails which will be provided
to you when the sessions recordings etc
will be shared and please be active on
the forum we are trying to build a forum
out here where interest common
interested people are there maybe in
future some of you will be collaborating
with each other to do some quantifiable
and qualitative research among
yourselves so happy learning thank you
very much thank you for team so just a
little more in detail about the
questions about machine learning the
main point is to demonstrate how
different types of machine learning
methods could be applied to the data and
how to overcome some of the issues
because the data is very specific so
we'll talk a lot more about the
different types of methods how to
combine methods how to use them for
identification of patterns and how to
use those patterns to classify or
discriminate between samples and develop
essentially signatures of mutations
disappear would you like to add anything
about that we will try to to give you an
idea of what this machine learning and
how we can use it for genomics data
because it is really difficult to use
machine learning for genomics data it's
this data are very special and no
okay thank you and as we wrap up I just
do want to mention that the cost of the
program is $135 but you will get a
discount code after this webinar for
those that participated so if you would
like to register until Monday next week
and if there are any issues you can talk
directly to Sahil I will just add here
the email is he'll at i/o so if you have
any questions about the payment and/or
the process please reach out to him also
what you see on the screen is we do
provide a certificate jointly together
with the tower bioinformatics Research
Center if you have participated in the
sessions and you've actually done the
things that are already there we do have
a limited number of spots in the program
so please let us know if you're
interested we are going to be talking
more about the program structure and the
topics again in the first session that
will be held on the 23rd so unless you
have any more questions I want to again
give an overview here so July 23rd to
September 28th
if you cannot yes we do have a calendar
in fact if you go to this link right
here and you can take a look at
curriculum so you will see all of the
dates are right here those dates
correspond with a week so though some
weeks we'll have two meetings and we
explore have one meeting but you will
see here the description of the topics
and what exactly will be covered during
that week if you need more details about
the times
so there will be on a consistent time
and we will provide a recording of that
session if you're not able to join you
have the access to the recording and
apart from that we also hold Q&A
sessions if you have any particular
subject that you're interested in we
didn't cover it or we didn't cover
efficiently we will have dedicated Q&A
sessions for VAX
all right great
well thank you everyone again we'll be
sending you an email shortly after this
session and we'll be starting next week
so we're really excited about starting
this and hope to see you there